Das ist wirklich unglaublich ein russisches forschungsteam will jetzt zwei arten von würmern erfolgreich
wiederbelebt haben diese fadenwürmer sollen vor etwa
42.000 jahren im permafrostboden in sibirien eingeschlossen worden sein doch sie waren wohl nicht tot sondern krüger
konserviert wie das forschungsteam vorgegangen ist wie die würmer es geschafft haben jahrtausende mainz zu überleben und was diese entdeckung für die suche nach
außerirdischem leben bedeutet mit diesen fragen beschäftigen wir uns jetzt bei klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Beim auftauen ließ sich das forschungsteam zeit und die spannung stieg ins unermessliche
mehrere wochen lang haben sie ihren fund in petrischalen auftauen lassen und je mehr das eis schmolz
umso lebendiger wurden die darin enthaltenen würmer aber die ganze geschichte für euch von vorne die
permafrost proben hatten die forscher in sibirien gefunden genauer gesagt in der abgelegenen republik sacher und 300 proben hatten die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler analysiert und zwei ausgewählt in denen sich gut erhaltenen nematoden befanden
übrigens auch als fadenwürmer bekannt sie sind mit einem durchmesser von weniger als einem millimeter zwar sehr klein sorgen aber immer mal wieder für überraschungen
sie wurden nämlich beispielsweise in einer tiefe von rund einem kilometer unterhalb der erdoberfläche
entdeckt was tiefer ist als
jeder andere mehr zähler ebenfalls auch im darm von schnecken und wieder andere fadenwürmer die auf einer insel im indischen ozean leben können fünf
verschiedene münder entwickeln je nachdem welcher für die gerade verfügbare nahrung am geeignetsten ist
eine der proben der aktuellen studie bestand jedenfalls aus einem permafrost brocken der aus einer tiefe von 30 metern ans tageslicht
befördert worden waren nach einschätzung des russischen
forschungsteams war dieser permafrostboden bereits seit 32 jahren 1000 jahren gefordert die anderen probe stammte aus einer tiefe von drei metern
ist wohl nach vermutung der wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler schon
42.000 jahre alt das haben sie durch die sogenannte
radiocarbon methode ermittelt dieses verfahren basiert darauf dass die menge an gebundenen
radioaktiven c14 atom in abgestorbenen organismen
abnimmt und zwar gemäß dem zerfalls gesetz die
petrischalen wurden dann wie gesagt über mehrere wochen bei 20 grad celsius gelagert und die würmer wurden immer
lebendiger irgendwann fingen die lebewesen an die nährstoffe aufzunehmen
und sich zu bewegen sie waren also offensichtlich nicht tot sondern nur konserviert heißt also so viel wie
konserviert durch einfrieren das ist tatsächlich das erste mal dass mehrzellige organismen die im
permafrost eingefroren waren wieder belebt werden konnten bei allen häfen samen und sporen ist das bereits bekannt sie können auch nach
millionen von jahren in denen sie eingefroren waren noch lebensfähig sein bei komplexeren organismen wie den fadenwürmern hatte man das
phänomen zwar auch schon beobachtet doch dabei betrug die längste eingefrorene zeitspanne
lediglich 39 jahre auch hier waren sie in aktiviert und konnten wieder belebt werden ein ähnliches ergebnis
hatten japanische forschungsteams auch schon bei den sogenannten
bärtierchen diese waren nach einer früher konservierung von 30 jahren noch lebensfähig beide ergebnisse
reichen natürlich nicht an die nun vermutete zeitspanne von
42.000 jahren heran doch wie glaubwürdig ist das forschungsergebnis
wirklich das russische team jedenfalls versichert die versuche so steril wie möglich durchgeführt zu haben um spätere
kontaminationen der proben auszuschließen wie genau die nematoden
diese lange zeit überstehen konnten das ist noch nicht geklärt dennoch ist diese entdeckung nicht nur für die biologie und medizin von großer bedeutung
hier könnte durch weitere forschung
möglicherweise die frage beantwortet werden wie wir auch menschliches gewebe lange erhalten können auch für die astrobiologie die auf der suche nach
außerirdischen leben ist ist die aktuelle studie äußerst spannend
lebewesen die im eis des mars zum beispiel gefunden würden könnten unter umständen wieder belebt werden
wahnsinn ab sofort könnt ihr auch bei klicks um mitglied werden für einen monatlichen betrag
bekommt ihr neben ein paar privilegien ein extra video und einen extra live stream nur für euch einfach hier unten auf
mitglied werden klicken und wenn er kein video zum thema
chronik und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die etwas
unzuverlässige abo boxer auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video kriegen mich
immer eine nachricht dazu einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meine schwester karla kick zum social media abonnieren
dafür hier klicken da aber nicht die
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch dortigen chronik tiefgekühlt zum ewigen leben bis dann bleib dran